tracy is in tacoma washington hi tracy
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave long time listener and fan
thanks for my call for taking my call
sure how can we help all righty so my
husband and i owe 160 000 on our house
and we currently have a hundred thousand
dollars
cash so we thought about refinancing but
our previous loan person said it's best
to do a credit union loan as rates would
be lower and you don't have to pay
closing
so it will only be like a sixty thousand
dollar loan they're right
so i was wondering what you would do
they gave me like a ton of different
options it's pretty overwhelming and
just as a side note my husband has ms so
we have
you know our six month fund and
everything like that so we're just
trying to get our
monthly payments as low as possible in
case something was to happen with his
diagnosis
your husband has what uh multiple
sclerosis
oh oh ms okay yes i didn't hear you how
long has he had that
um about a year okay and what's your
household income
um well it's about 55 000
after taxes my husband where did the 100
000 come from
um just random family gifts and then we
saved
a lot you've done well done very well
and you're 100 debt free except your
home
correct your loan officer is giving you
excellent advice
absolutely okay good let me walk you
through a couple of things to watch for
okay when a credit union or a local bank
makes a loan like this
it's a loan they are going to keep at
the bank
they're not making it by underwriting
guidelines of fannie mae or fha
it's called a portfolio loan they're
going to keep it in their portfolio
okay so it's kind of like a home equity
loan in a sense
they're going to keep it there they're
going to keep it there at the bank
okay so as long as you know that then
that what that tells you is
that whatever rules they want to make up
they can do so this idea that somehow
they have to conform to some other
guidelines is a bunch of crap
and so here's what you are going to make
them do what's this house worth
um it's worth 325. okay so a 60 000
loan on a 325 000 house is what's known
as a no freaking brainer
right unless you've got horrible credit
or you're in bankruptcy okay
so what you are going to demand is three
things
okay one is no closing costs of any kind
under any circumstances okay
they need to put they need to do this to
get this loan
two is a fixed rate
okay and three is
a fixed term
uh do you want a 10 year or a 15 year
probably a 10 will be fine in this case
but you do not get a traditional home
equity loan where the rate floats
and thereby the length of time that
you're in the loan floats and some of
those even have
balloons or calls after three years or
five
years okay you don't want any of that
you want a 10 year
loan that pays off in 10 years that's
called a fully amortizing loan
at a set rate with no closing costs
there is a local bank or credit union
that will be happy
to make you that loan okay cool
you're going to have to push back though
because they don't always use their
brains at the bank you know that
i do i'm a mom so i'm used to push back
so i think i'll say okay
they're gonna go now you need to get a
home equity loan and this is our home
equity loan product and i'm going i
don't care what your home equity loan
product is
if you want this loan it's gonna be
these three things
okay perfect well thank you so much
steve thank you so much anthony you guys
have a great day
you too you too great job by that loan
officer telling him
that's a good loan officer told him not
to make a loan with him
dave i was shocked that's good that's
good integrity i like that because it's
a 60 000 home loan with a
traditional mortgage is super expensive
right and the mortgage companies don't
want to screw with it and they're
they're going to run the rate up number
one if they do screw with it because
it's so small
and they're probably going to hit you
with a bunch of extra side fees uh that
don't need to happen so when you're
making a very a small loan like that
under 75 000
uh especially where there's a bunch of
equity yeah always go to your local
credit union always go to your local
bank and always remember those three
things i told you no closing costs fixed
rate
fully amortizing fixed term i've i've
seen some credit unions dave do it
uh below a hundred thousand well they
will they'll do it alone yeah yeah
they'll do it they'll do a loan over
over over 75 but when you get 75 000 and
under a traditional fha or fannie mae
loan
becomes unwieldy it's very expensive got
you and most of the
most of the mortgage companies don't
want to screw with that yeah but the
credit unions will
and the you know local bank will
especially in a situation like this so
very very well done good good job of
that loan officer that's good stuff